Hey everyone.
Uh, welcome to
Comic-Con at home.
I'm so happy you
could join us for this
virtual panel with
a cast and producers
of The Capture,
which is streaming
exclusively on Peacock.
My name is Philiana Ng,
Senior Editor of TV
at Entertainment Tonight.
We're going to be
digging into this
excellent British drama.
That explores the
kind of increasingly
blurred lines
between what's real.
And what's not.
In the show, ask
the question in this
kind of post truths era.
Can we really believe
what we see.
But before we dig into
this series, I'm gonna
introduce the panelists
who are spread out across
two continents.
First from the UK,
we have series creator,
writer and director
Ben Chanan.
- Hello.
- Executive producer, Rosie Alison
- Holliday Grainger
who plays
Detective Inspector Rachel Carey.
- Hi, guys.
- Callum Turner,
who plays Shaun Emery.
- Hello.
- And from the US we
have Ron Perlman
who plays Frank Napier.
- Hey.
- And Famke Janssen
who plays Jessica Mallory,
someone we meet
later in the series.
- Hey everyone.
Awesome.
Hi guys.
Thanks for hopping
on and doing this.
Has this been--
Has it been awhile
since you've all
kind of seen each
other. In kind of,
one room or when
you know, how--
We've all been in lockdown.
many, many months.
I've seen it--
I think it was about
a year ago at a wrap party.
Yeah, I like the one in
Gelson's actually.
Yeah, but yeah, just
seen a lot of Callum
over the computer.
Awesome.
Before we get into the
Q&A, we're going
to play the trailer
just so everyone
at home can kind of
get a better idea
of what the show is.
Ben do you want to
kind of tee up what
the show is about?
The show came about
through my work in documentaries,
as I realized,
I worked with
the police quite a lot
in documentaries,
and I realized that,
increasingly, people
are getting convicted
through video evidence
more and more reliably.
And at the same time,
you can now get apps on
your phone that take,
you know, do digital
face transplants that
are cheap, effective,
and convincing.
I thought to myself,
you know, what if those
two technological and
criminological developments
were to collide.
So that was the
inspiration for it.
Cool.
Yeah, let's play
the trailer.
In the last few hours, dramatic
footage has emerged online.
Depicting a man
believed to be former
soldier, Shaun Emery
attacking and abducting a woman.
That's him,
A woman's missing.
And Shaun Emery is our suspect.
Is anyone going to tell
me what the problem is,
You're under suspicion
for assault and kidnapping.
You do know that your
suspect's a national hero?
Two tours in Afghanistan,
one in Iraq.
And how do we
repay his service?
You mind telling
me where she is?
What happened between
you and Hannah Roberts?
She kissed me.
She got on a bus.
That's the last
I've seen her.
This ain't what happened.
This isn't what happened!
None of this happened!
This ain't real!
What have you done?!
What do you
mean he's gone?
He's escaped from
an emergency exit.
Run facial rec,
make him a target.
Shawn claims this is
somehow being fabricated.
Almost anything is
possible these days.
If properly done,
it's impossible to prove.
What are we tip-toeing around for?
I think someone's
tampering with evidence.
We don't know whose
turf we're treading on.
I understand you have this drive,
but counter-intelligence,
you can rarely see
the whole picture.
I like when they say move along,
nothing to see.
They're lying.
The police think I've done it.
My ex thinks I've done it.
and between me and
you, there are moments
when I'm scared that I die.
If you knew what was at stake,
you would walk away and pretend
this never happened.
The intelligence
community has hurt
a lot of people.
I need to find
the soldier.
Find out what school
his daughter goes to.
If she could see what we're working on,
I'm talking about images,
that'll haunt you for
the rest of your life.
While you're watching everybody else,
don't ever assume
there isn't somebody
watching me.
Nice trailer.
I mean I'm getting anxious, just
kind of like after that trailer.
How are you guys feeling?
It's so good to see it again.
It's been so long
it's made me
feel really excited.
It's pretty dynamic.
It's one of the--
it's very rare
to have a writer director
do the whole thing
So Ben has both written
all six episodes,
directed them all
and he just, he's a
master storyteller.
And he came up with this
extraordinary sort of
unmissable thriller,
where you really, it
makes you think it's
got the big picture.
The big picture
paranoia or about the
uncertainty of digital
manipulation, but he
also was very sure to
make you feel as well.
And so he's got
these two fantastic
lead characters.
Uh, Shaun, the soldier.
Who's caught on
CCTV, apparently
committing a crime,
which he denies and
then Holliday, the
detective who begins.
To investigate and
unravel the truth of
what really happened
and is our sort of,
eyes on the moral
maze of the story.
But, uh, but it's all
credit to Ben so
I should stop talking,
but it's really rare
to find this master
storyteller who can do
all these things and
bring them together.
Yeah,
Thank you very much.
I mean, I certainly
didn't realize,
how contemporary
it was going to be.
I started writing
this before the
term deep faith.
I I'd heard of it
before it became a.
A common phrase,
even fake news.
Wasn't really a
household phrase when
I started writing.
And then as I was
writing, the sort of
the news started to
catch up with the story.
I started to factor
in the language
of the day into the,
into the dialogue.
Otherwise it would
have felt weird people
not referencing those
things, but clearly
we're living through a
time when every piece of
footage, every piece of
news is being questioned
and rightly so.
Uh, but then the flip
side of that is that
that's being exploited
by people as well.
where it suits
certain politicians too.
If we don't quite
know what's real.
Yeah.
I mean, you kind of
mentioned the two
kind of amazingly
characters.
Holliday, you play Rachel, who is
this ambitious kind of eager?
Very skilled
detective.
Who's kind of thrown
into the mix in
this high profile
Shaun Emery case.
Right.
Uh, what stood out to
you about Rachel that
kind of immediately
drew you in.
I kind of love
that when I first
started reading the
scripts, I didn't know
if I liked her or not.
And that it was, it
was a sort of, because
she doesn't really care.
It's like she's there
to do a job and then
she's ambitious and
she wants to do well
and prove herself.
And, you know,
she's, she kind of,
she's not necessarily
a people pleaser.
And I just love
Ben's, um, way that
Ben weaves such a moral
conundrum for Carey,
throughout the whole
series that she's,
you know, when we first
met her, she has such
faith in the authorities
and the institution
of the police.
And, but she also has
like an incredibly
strong moral compass
and a need to fight for.
And get to the bottom
of the truth.
And when those two
aspects of her sort
of her faiths
like collide,
it's a, this is kind
of complete yeah.
Moral maze that
she goes through.
Awesome.
And Callum, I
mean, first of all,
congratulations on
your BAFTA tv nomination.
Was that a
pleasant surprise?
Yeah, it was a
lovely surprise.
Yeah.
What intrigued me
about Shaun was kind of,
there was a point in
the series when even
he starts to question
his own understanding
of the truth. As an
actor, how did you kind
of approach playing.
That internal
struggle, like he's
constantly on edge.
Well, I was, I was
saw Shaun as like a
freedom fighter out of his
own mind, in some
sense, because you
meet this man as he's
in the limelight, he's
famous for something
that no one wants to
really be famous for,
for killing someone
and he's questioning
how he got there, how
he got to that place.
And he's really
trying to change.
How the world views him,
how his family view him.
And how his friends
view him.
How he views himself.
And he's, he's
about to do that.
He gets off with the
case in the first
episode, and then
he's driving back into
this nightmare.
On a higher level.
It could be like a
long day's journey into
the night kind of man,
searching for his soul
journey that he goes on.
I just wanted
to do that.
And then on top
of that, it was.
Working with Ben
and Holliday,
and Rosie and those
guys in the BBC.
And, uh, and the
character that was
really intelligent.
I think both the
characters that Holliday
and I have. Are working
out as we're going
along and alongside the audience.
And I think that's
one of the reasons
that it's so gripping
because no one's ahead
of anyone, any stage.
Yeah, definitely.
Ron, I mean,
you've made a career
out of playing bad asses
I feel like,
Like Hellboy and Clay
and Sons of Anarchy.
Frank kind of falls
under that umbrella
too, but there's a
limit to his power.
What was appealing
to you about Frank
and the lengths that
he kind of goes to
complete his missions?
Very similar to what
Holliday said, you
know, first thing
you want to do is
figure out where you
fit into this story.
And the thing that was
so smart about the way
Ben rendered Frank, was
that, all the way
to the end, you don't
know whether you're
dealing with the good
guy or the bad guy.
You don't know.
No.
Whether you're supposed
to feel sympathy for
for this guy's
plight or how he
views his place in
the world and his job.
Or whether he's a
monster, um, and we'll
do anything in order to,
justify his agenda.
His agenda seems
rather to be the tail
is wagging the dog.
And so the
whole kind of thing
is a, is a mind.
I can't use the word.
Right.
Anyway, if I,
if I could use the
word mind, I would
use it, but I can't.
But, the notion of,
of there not
being any relief for the
audience to figure out.
Wait a minute.
I'm having so
much trouble keeping
track of.
Who's the good guy here.
Who's the bad guy here.
And you know, Frank,
uh, is the head of the
class when it comes
to, to that
head fake.
Definitely, Famke
you're, you're no
stranger to playing
fierce women and,
and Jessica Mallory,
although she doesn't
come in until like
late into the season,
Jessica Mallory is,
is someone who kind of
lord's over Frank
a little bit.
Right.
Uh, and, and your
introduction kind of,
you make quite a splash
when you come in.
Uh, what do you
want people to know
about Jessica and
what did you like
about this character?
Foremost, I was
very excited to be
part of this project
because l thought Ben
did such an incredible
job with spring place.
And I've been spending my
time between London
and New York for the
last couple of years.
And I was just
struck when I was in
London, but how many
CCTV camera's there
are, I've never seen
anything quite like it.
And I wanted to get
very much involved in
the whole big brother
sort of conspiracy
theory and whatever so.
When I read this
piece, I was like, this
is so of the moment.
This is so timely.
This whole notion
of fake news, of not
knowing what's real, but
constantly having to.
Fact check and double
check everything.
And this is an
absolutely frightening
notion of what could
happen in the world,
in where we, you know,
in the world that
we live in today.
And so I thought it
was the story that had
to be told, and it was
done so well by Ben.
And then the
cast that he put
together, as you know,
he obviously is
an amazing producer.
So it was just a, uh,
there was, it was a
no brainer in terms of
signing up to do it.
And, we, Ron
and I had just worked
on Asher the year
prior, a movie,
that Ron also are produced.
And, and so it was
really nice to come in
and have a different,
the dynamic between
us as characters
than we had before.
And sort of coming
in as this booming,
you know, dark
figure from the CIA.
And we're not entirely
sure what her motives
are and how deep this,
potential conspiracy
or whatever it is runs.
So those were some of
the reasons why I
ended up saying yes.
Plus I got to be
in London, which is
one of my favorite
places in the world.
So yeah.
Pretty awesome deal.
For the cast,
I mean.
Were you familiar with
this world before?
Uh, what kind of prep
work did you do to.
Become familiar
with this world, if
you weren't before
and to play
your characters.
Yeah.
I felt like
I was familiar with
the, uh, detective
world just from watching
detective shows.
I love The Killing,
I love the Bridge.
I've always been a fan
of them, but, you
know, I didn't really
know much about the
actual police force.
But Ben's script
and it was
so well researched
that reading them.
I felt like I.
You know, I could see
the differences between
my expectations and
what was on the page.
Well I managed to
get a, and work
my way in with the
mat and do a week's
shattering in the
homicide department,
and also shattered
a couple of other women
that were at Carey's
level that had a similar
background to her, and
that had transferred
freshly to homicide.
And that was.
Just to see what
actually happens and
to pick people's brains
as well, to just, you
know, try and find holes
in transcript script.
And there weren't any,
it was like, you know,
to like to say, does
this, did it happen?
Would this happen?
Like, and just
the terminology used
and everything was,
was amazing.
And also Ben's set up,
a few meetings with,
uh, his counter-terror
advisor, which was
completely like.
Eye-opening and mind
blowing as to, you
know, what is probably
happening what's
possibly happening, what
definitely is happening.
Yeah, that was interesting.
You ended up on
the actual mother
investigation, huh?
Yeah.
I like when I kind of,
there were like three,
what I was surprised
with is how many invest,
like, like a homicide
detective, how many
investigations they
cover at the same time?
And one of them was
a cold case that
was in my area.
And I ended up on a,
she'd not been to the
crime scene before.
So I ended up on a walk
around of the crime
scene in my local area.
And because I knew the
park better than them,
I was just like, Oh
no, no, no, this is
the quickest entrance.
This is the narrows
entrance, the pond.
And these are the woods
and felt like I was
like, you know,
I was determined.
I was going
to solve that.
I was, they were still
looking for the body
like a few years later.
And I still think
when I walked through
that path, I might
come across it.
Wow.
That's amazing.
I mean, Callum, what
kind of shocked or
surprised you in
kind of researching
like surveillance
culture and,
doing research too?
The thing that actually
shocked me the most was
how much fun soldiers
have when they're on
tour and how much, uh,
enjoyment there is and
how it becomes quickly.
They're normally,
there's I guess, being
so close to death.
All the time.
You have to live every
moment as it comes
with as if it is your
last moment, you know,
your friends, not
everyone's dying all
the time, but people
die around you and
you are close to that.
And that was
the thing that
surprised me the most.
And then also I did some
weapons training, uh,
which was interesting.
And since the violence
stuff, too.
You aced the weapons training.
Why was it interesting?
Why was it interesting
because they're so
powerful and loud and
they're shoot, I'm
shooting a snipper is.
It's it's, it's quite
an intense experience
and I hadn't shot, I
shot hand guns before,
but hadn't shot massive.
It hurts, you know.
Your surveillance training
sounded intense as well.
Yeah.
My surveillance training was.
I think I'm a bit jealous
of you for that.
was like, try and
try and dodge.
You should do it for the next.
Yeah, maybe I should.
Did you take that up?
It was a lot of fun.
I ended up following
people around London,
trying to avoid
getting caught.
And then,
and then trying not
to get caught.
It was a lot of fun.
Wow.
That's amazing.
I mean, for Ron
and maybe Famke
it to me as a viewer
does watching the show,
like I found myself
kind of trying to crack
the code on who was
actually good, who was
evil, who was telling
the truth, whose story
actually believe.
Did you find yourself
kind of doing that as
you were reading the
script and as you were
kind of filming.
That's one of the reasons
why I signed
on, because it is
really, it was a page
turner and it's the
same when you watch it.
It's constantly,
you're constantly
questioning everything
and everybody,  you
know, what is the truth?
And that is something
that we're just
dealing with on a
daily basis today.
It is so absolutely
of the moment, it's
so timely the show.
So I, you know, that is.
Incredible.
I wish I had been able
to do any kind of on
the ground, CIA, but
I have no connections there.
Because that would
seem fascinating
to be, you know,
with people like that.
Next time, one
day, hopefully.
Yeah, I, I
feel horrible.
I don't have great
stories to share with
you about my research
and stuff that Callum
and Holliday were
talking about, but ride
alongs and shadowing.
Uh, I wish I had, I
realized that I was
joining a world,
that I didn't
know a great deal
about in terms of,
you know, internal,
ministrations of
how things, uh, Uh,
responsibilities are
handed down and what
one does in the name
of pulling one's weight
and, and, uh, so.
For me,  it was
deferring completely
to, uh, to Ben.
This was his world.
He had a very strong
notion about,
not only the world
that I was occupied,
but, uh, but also how
he interacted with
all of the other,
uh, areas of law
enforcement, you know?
All the areas of law
enforcement are, are
represented in the show.
You have local,
you have state,
you have a federal
international, and
you know, where Frank
comes in is like, you
know, he's a stranger
in a strange land.
He's an American
operative in the UK.
So immediately everybody
looks at him side eye,
and suspect.
And as if he has some
sort of a strange
representation of some
diabolical thing that
exists on the other
side of the pond.
So right off the bat,
he's being regarded a
skew and then you meet
him and you realize
that's very justified,
that, you know,
people should be,
suspect of, of what
America's interests are.
And what,
particularly what
this guy's, modus
operandi, includes,
in the name of
keeping people safe,
where does that concept
and, and some sort of
personal agenda about,
human rights begin.
And so that's the
exercise of Frank
and for me, it was,
an exercise
and deferring to the
filmmaker, the guy who
wrote the thing and the
guy who was going to
actually, you know, get
these performances out
of us in order to,
realize his vision.
And that was, that
was everything to me.
For the actors.
I mean, how has your
role in, in this show,
kind of changed
your view on, on
surveillance and has
it made you more aware
of cameras and,
and make you.
More protective of
your own kind of
personal privacy.
I definitely,
started noticing cameras
more than I did before.
And, I'm very
incredibly private
as a person.
I don't do social
media or anything
that, you know, to
protect my privacy.
Everything is turned
off on my phone in terms
of location services
and all of that kind of
stuff, but just knowing
the ends to which
people can go and how
incredibly complicated
it is in today's world,
have any type of privacy
and what you do and say
can be used against you.
And then with
manipulation of
existing footage
makes it even more
frightening to me.
And it's almost like,
all the, all of
the care you take
in preserving
your privacy.
What this show did
for me was say,
it doesn't really
matter what you do.
They're listening and
they're watching and
they can do anything
that they want with
that information,
depending on what kind
of mood they're in at
any given time, which
is all depending on,
who's sitting in the, in
the seat of power,
which comes into play
in this story as well.
You know, we have
politicians in high
places, all around the
world that are telling
you, you didn't see
what you just saw.
Those are
our leaders.
So what kind of a
shot do we have at
maintaining, you
know, some sort of
a real perspective?
I think.
The timing of Ben
wanting to tell
this story is
just phenomenal.
One of the, one of
the things that comes
through so clearly
from the show is
that we all know the
phrase, big brother is
watching you, but what
Ben's done is taken
it to the next level.
And said big brother's not just
watching you, he can
do all these different
things with your, you
know, it's the digital
manipulation element
that is really scary
and is the next step
and personal paranoia.
Yeah.
I mean, that kind
of leads into my
next question.
Kind of perfectly
like, has your paranoia
kind of grown as a
result of, of being
part of this project?
Well, 1984, Brave
New World are two
of my favorite books.
And I know
Ben loves him too.
And what's so
brilliant about his
show is it stays true
to the conspiracy
thriller, natureof it,
you know,
the parallax views and.
Is it three nights on the condo?
Three nights on the car?
Three Days of the Condor.
Yeah.
That kind of, those
kinds of movies.
And it stays
true to that.
And it takes
us on the journey.
It's also, I think ep.
four is kind of like
Rambo First Blood.
I don't know what you
think Ben
I love it that it didn't appear
to me when I wrote it.
But when you said
it, I thought, yeah.
Okay.
That's a good movie.
That's another seventies right?
The seventies,
or was it 1980?
Come on Rosie,
you know.
I didn't
know when it was
possibly 1980, but
it's that it's that
sort of, I would have
Blow Up, Blow Out,
Blow Up and Blow Out.
So that, to the
list of things,
films that inspired
this conversation
this conversation. I mean,
to have those movies
as your inspiration,
you know, I'm putting
it into today's world.
Yeah.
And there is just that
whole thing that we've
all grown up thinking
that there is such a
thing as documentary
evidence and it's
a gold standards.
And now we're in an age
where we just have to
accept that documentary
evidence, just ain't
documentary evidence
anymore necessarily.
Yeah.
I'm going through
this really weird
period where I just.
Find the, the, the
notion of how much
information we have
access to and, and
how much is just being
poured on us on a daily
basis because of the
24 hour news cycle and
social media and things,
ways of getting there.
Uh huh.
Tidbits of situations
that are so outlandishly
unjust that you can't
do a thing about.
So.
No.
At what point do you
completely turn off?
At what point do
you become cynical?
At what point
do you give up?
At what point do
you say, you know, I
can't, they ever, for
the grace of God go,
I can't fix all of
the ills of the world.
So I'm just going to
stick to my little tiny
little corner, you know?
Oh, what's that Greg,
you know, I'm going
to just sit in my
little more couch
from watching my
little 60 inch TV and.
Just leave me alone.
Let me have my beer.
But yeah, it's,
it's overwhelming.
I mean, for me, I didn't
even know anything about
the concept of CCTV
until I read the script.
Then I arrived in London and,
every time I looked up,
somebody was looking
back at me and this
is something that I
hadn't even begun to,
you know, fold into
to my consciousness.
Because you guys, you
guys don't have anything.
Nothing else to worry about.
I mean, you know, now
what do I do about that?
You know?
Cause if I don't have
enough to worry about.
Well, yeah, cause
this is Comic-Con
and many of you have kind of
ties to big franchises
like X-Men and Hellboy
and Fantastic Beast.
I have to ask,
like, what do you
guys geek out over,
personally?
Like what is your kind
of big nerd obsession?
I'll start with Holliday.
I could kill
over and I think you
already said it and
getting like, so it was
like detective shows.
So like The Killing,
The Bridge, Luther.
Prime Suspect.
Yeah,
Documentary series
that's mine.
Love them
I still geek out
over Cary Grant.
I'm sorry.
Who doesn't?
That's my black
and white thirties
and forties movies.
All my refuge.
That's where I escaped
to, the notion of a
more ordered world, less
self-indulgent world, a
more sophisticated world
where not everybody was
crying in their beer.
People were just
getting on with it.
And the level of
discourse was
sophisticated and
dripping with charm.
No matter what I
do, that's why I
keep going back to
that's my refuge.
Mine's mine's always
comedies and it varies
in it's in my watching,
I'm watching
a lot of Modern
Family right now.
I love that show.
And Ben and Rosie,
what about guys?
I, I geek out over
Hellboy, X-Men.
Fantastic Beast, Harry Potter.
Seinfeld is my thing
that I just I've
watched all my life.
I continue to watch it.
I watch it.
My family throughout
lockdown, it's kind of
kept just sane. It's not
much better than, than.
Eating a pizza and
watching Seinfeld
it's a good shower.
And in time of sorrow,
I turned to Gene
Kelly, he's my go to a
particular numbers that
I watched over and over,
but I did just watch
Normal People twice.
So I enjoyed
that so much.
The,
yeah.
Awesome.
Well, lastly, before we
wrap, I mean, one thing
The Capture gets at
is that the truth is.
Very complicated.
Right.
And extremely layered.
And the show also kind of
raises very important
moral questions.
Ben I'll throw it to you.
What do you want people
to take away from
the series and what
questions you want
people to ask that
they didn't before?
I suppose the essential
question is in a
world where every
piece of video footage
could be manipulated.
How can we
believe what we see?
Awesome.
Very succinct.
Cool.
Well, I think that's
all the time we have.
I mean, thank you so
much for joining
the cast and producers
of The Capture for
this virtual
Comic-Con home panel,
you can watch all six
episodes of the first
season, exclusively
on NBC Universal
streaming service
Peacock, and the series
will be back for
a second season
at some point.
Yeah.
Thanks again to Ben
Rosie, Holliday, Callum,
Ron, and Famke for
a great discussion.
Thanks guys.
Nice to see you.
I see.
Great to see everybody.
Big
guys.
Lovely painting.
Oh, thank you.
I just finished it and
I had to cover it there.
So I cover the painting.
That was not
that I didn't do.
So I thought, let
me just put that.
So
how lovely.
Yes, I think locked
down for months
was wonderful.
It's such a great,
great.
All right.
Nice seeing everybody.
See.